les participants ont pu admirer en cette
journée je dirais l'ossature même du
musée une pièce de musée elle même
cette ferme de marquez et mieux
comprendre grâce à des documents réunis
alentours dans trois grands ce les
raisons de l'effort entrepris mais eux
restent qui mieux que monsieur delaunay
dont on connaît l'attachement au monde
de la terre pouvait tirer la leçon de
cette journée vous savez c'est une
création de qualité
ce n'est pas une création de quantité ce
que cela représente c'est un point
exceptionnel ou s'associeront le respect
du passé l'image de ce qu'était une
civilisation un aspect culturel et
d'animations pour l'avenir et cela
représente donc de ce fait un endroit
qui c'est un endroit modèle est un
endroit où l'homme reprendra contact
avec la nature et oubliera un petit peu
les soucis qui l'assaillent dans sa
ville